hello hello I am Charlie I've been
making videos for the internet since
2007 which means I used to make stuff
like this have you ever wondered what a
man would look like if his entire body
were painted purple I like my tea quite
milky hello YouTube
I thought was about time for me to start
making vlogs however needless to say
time has passed and I'm pretty different
to how I used to be so today I'm gonna
get you up to speed on Who I am now
number one I'm a filmmaker thus far I've
made four short films the T Chronicles
offline strangers in a bed and our
brother all of which you can find on my
youtube channel right now I am in the
middle of writing a brand new short film
which have taken a time over more than
previous ones and if all goes to plan it
should be finished by the end of the
year number two I'm a morning person
which is mostly alive but I am a writer
and host of the YouTube breakfast show
cereal time which goes out every weekday
morning here in the UK
together with my friend Jimmy and our
producer Josh we just have fun really
and make silly things to help you wake
up in the morning or whenever it is you
decide to watch the show we are not
picking number three I exist I am a man
with a wonderful girlfriend and an
adorable cat and I love video games and
movies and podcasts and I read too many
think pieces and I'm fallible and overly
sensitive and usually anxious and a
human being which may seem like an
obvious thing to mention but in my
experience the fact that the Internet is
made up of real people with real
feelings seems to be a surprisingly easy
thing to forget so I am real number four
I'm a writer so this is my big project
that I'm working on this year I am
writing a book it's called fun science
and four goes to plan it will be coming
out in October this year I may not be a
scientist but I am a huge fan of science
I love sharing science with people and
so my goal for this book is to try and
create more people like me more science
fans in the book itself I'm gonna be
taking you on a quick tour through all
of science giving you my favorite
scientific facts all of the information
you need to understand just how cool
those facts actually are as well as many
a silly digression and lots of
illustrations as well like that one by
my friend Fran who is brilliant
so there we are a real-life book that I
will be writing myself which is not
something
have to say but the the times we live in
and if you would like to get yourself a
copy then firstly thank you for even
wanting to that's awesome and there's a
link in the description to get one on
Amazon cheese number five I'm a video
blogger as I said before I have been
doing this video blog in Milwaukee for a
long time now and although my
relationship with it has gone through
some ebbs and flows over the years I
really do still love doing it I love
connecting with people across the world
and I genuinely do think the vlogging
could be a force for good today I just
want to use YouTube for my own pleasure
more than anything else so don't expect
any kind of strict schedule from me or
any particular style I'm just gonna make
whatever the hell I like and hopefully
you'll like it too
so yeah thank you very much for watching
and I'll see you in the next one goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool I know it's me
Gideon and hunger to say this - charlie
world but you should definitely buy his
book - usually good okay thank you
goodbye